embark on a bold new journey in rising
tide the upcoming expansion to
civilization beyond Earth lead your
civilization into the unknown brave the
brutal hostility of frigid worlds and
command the fear for respect of other
leaders as you shift the tide of the
political landscape with all new
enhanced diplomatic features a strong
leader has nothing without a land to
rule over and in a rising tide new
biomes await with challenges and
benefits of their own the frozen
wastelands of the frigid biome hide new
alien threats and Geographic obstacles
but are ripe with hidden artifacts and
new marvels this treacherous wilderness
has much to offer new civilizations if
they can withstand the cold as the first
wave of colony ships rose to leave earth
behind they left in their wake several
civilizations that had not yet conceded
to the fate presented by the great
mistake with worldwide sea levels rising
many island nations reshaped themselves
to better survive life on the high seas
as a result when these societies emerged
from the global Dark Age and began
seeding new worlds of their own they
brought with them new technologies
better suited for an aquatic life
the North Sea Alliance led by the
stalwarts Scotsman Duncan Hughes
recognized the importance of being ready
for any situation and fashioned their
colony ships to allow for both land and
water landings likewise the German
political party integer emerged from the
Dark Age with a stronger understanding
of the need for successful cohabitation
with the worlds they would call home led
by the for thinking humanist Lena Abner
the integer Party builds their new
civilizations around the pillars of
sustainability innovation and diversity
living behind the irresponsible
extravagance that had doomed the world
they left behind with the emergence of
new factions came a diplomatic
revolution in her icing type the
diplomacy system has been enhanced to
give players new and improved ways to
interact with neighboring civilizations
as times change people change to reflect
this in a rising tide each civilizations
leader will now be able to develop
unique traits that evolve with them over
the course of a game character traits
give each leader you encounter a new
political spin shaping their attitudes
and responses to your actions of
diplomacy or war in addition players can
now assign traits to aspects of their
society like politics domestic
infrastructure and military might each
trait will further specialize your
society grant unique advantages and open
new pathways to coerce and conquer other
civilizations with the addition of
traits comes the opportunity to create
mutually beneficial agreements with
other leaders by pledging services to
another nation in exchange for their
services or political resources you can
further improve your diplomatic
positioning the stronger a relationship
is between two civilizations the more
impactful their agreements benefits
become the wisest leaders will be those
who use agreements to the
advantage align themselves with the
right political partners and striking
when the time is right to take full
advantage of the dealings they made in
addition to new traits and agreements
rising tide introduces two new
diplomatic measures fear and respect if
your nation takes a distinct lead in
military economic or political standing
other nations may become fearful of your
overwhelming power this fear can be used
to your advantage
to strong-arm other civilizations into
trades and agreements that are in your
favor but be cautious as other nations
may begin to conspire against you behind
your back if you prefer a more amicable
approach you can work to foster the
respect other leaders have for you a
leaders respect for you is improved by
playing into their specific leader
traits take actions that appeal to their
traits and they will look favorably upon
you allowing for the formation of
stronger agreements and better trade
conditions this was a further look into
the ever-changing landscape of a rising
tide in part three we'll reveal the
remaining factions explore the new types
of relationships you can foster with
other civilizations and examine the
exciting next evolution of the affinity
system coming to civilization beyond
Earth rising tide
you